hey everybody welcome back to one dream
now where we give you an inside look at
some of the shows currently streaming on
wandrium I'm rich Burnett and in today's
show we'll be discussing secret
societies and the Occult so dim the
lights light some candles and let's get
started
[Music]
today's guest is Rick Spence Rick is a
professor emeritus of history at the
University of Idaho and he specializes
in all kinds of cool subjects from
Espionage to occultism and secret
societies to name just a few his latest
series called secrets of the occult is
now streaming on wondering let's take a
look
the term occult tends to conjure up
images of robed cultists and midnight
sacrifices
part of the picture but only a very
small one
occult simply means hidden
it's a whole Hidden World of unknown
dimensions a world driven not by good or
evil but intent sometimes your intent
my name is Richard Spence and I invite
you to join me on a Magical Mystery Tour
of Illumination
exploring 30 000 years of fact myth and
speculation
over 24 episodes we'll delve into topics
such as divination Alchemy Witchcraft
and Satanism along with more surprising
subjects like UFOs Santa Claus and
quantum physics
we'll also explore the role occult
beliefs and practices played in
historical events such as the Russian
Revolution and the Third Reich along
with occultism's influence on crime
politics popular culture and religion
once you know what to look for you'll
see that they occult the hidden is all
around you and you'll never see the
world the same way again
Rick thank you for joining us today
so your new series is all about the
hidden and not so Hidden World of the
occult can you start us off by
explaining a bit about what the occult
is well it's interesting you use the
word hidden because all the occult
really means the term means is is hidden
specifically hidden from sight there are
all kinds of occult things hidden in
plain sight the idea is that there's
essentially is that there is a greater
reality which our senses our natural
abilities only allow us to see a part of
and apparently there's just all kinds of
cool stuff and spooky stuff in this
greater reality that we that those who
call themselves occultists seek to
access because you know that's for all
the real knowledge or some sort of
Greater now greater World greater
knowledge let's get into a little bit
about the actual content of your series
um as I was reading through the topics
that you cover one thing that I found
interesting personally was that you talk
about occult rituals quite a bit but one
in particular that I wanted to ask you
about was some surprising history about
Christmas traditions can you tell me a
little bit more about that
ritual of the Christmas tree
occult is something which is a world
which is hidden from View
a ritual is actually pretty simple you
know most people tend to think you have
to have robes and candles I don't know
and uh
goat or something but that's not really
necessary a ritual is simply a series of
actions performed in a certain order
and almost always with the intention of
creating a desired result
so let's look at the Christmas tree
uh the Christmas tree is a particular
type of tree I mean you don't generally
go out and get a mulberry tree it's
always an evergreen it's usually
positioned in some sort of place of
special place where it can be viewed
we're going to be seen and then you
proceed usually if you keep in mind in a
fairly ritualized process of decorating
it of adorning the tree
and the adorning the tree is is turning
it into it's being created for a
particular purpose
and once the tree is properly adorned
often capped with an angel which is kind
of interesting then eventually the gifts
that are will later be distributed are
placed underneath it in this position
there are in some ways sort of
Sanctified by being placed under the
tree they have to be placed under the
tree before you give them to people
another thing is is that almost nobody
thinks of this is a ritual it's just you
know it's a custom it's a habit it's a
convenient thing that we do but you know
when you're talking about Customs habits
just things that we do you're talking
about rituals it's just a matter of
semantics so a lot of Stories of the
occult have mysterious Origins a lot of
them feel like they come from far away
places
um but I know in your course you
actually discuss
uh the occult and uh origins of a cult
that start in America can you touch on
some of those
well America has a is a particular place
an interesting place in this regard
because
what you've got are sort of two groups
of humanity that
separated you know you have the old
world you know Eurasia and Africa which
all be you know for
thousands of years tens of thousands of
years mixed and matched Customs back and
forth a huge exchange of everything from
products to diseases and then you had a
migration of people from Northeastern
Asia into the Americas at some point
we're not entirely sure but let's say it
was 15 to 20 000 years ago and then
until you know 1492
they were cut off from the rest of
humanity
so one of the things which is
interesting is for all the differences
that you would find between Native
American civilizations and cultures and
old world as we call them civilizations
and cultures after those Millennia of
separation
well what's the same and one of the
things that you find which is the same
is that within American cultures within
Native American cultures as in Old World
cultures you have the occult you have
the concept of magic and spirits and a
greater hidden world and you have the
same people who try to access that you
know Puritans would you know basically
looked at Native traditions and argued
that ah you know every Idol they have is
the devil they're all doing devilish
things this is you know there was a
great fear of the Wilderness as being
the realm of Satan because it was this
many ways kind of
Untamed natural world
but again from the aspect of someone who
considered themselves an occultist all
of this is completely familiar it was a
common language which cultures separated
over thousands and thousands of years
could communicate through
so you bring up a name
um and of course no discussion about the
occult would be complete without
discussing
the biggest Baddie of them all satan so
you brought him up I'm curious how does
uh the the Devil Himself fit into The
Narrative of of the series
the earliest Old World Civilization that
we really know of the Sumerians
they had a whole variety of sort of you
know good spirits and bad spirits good
bad good spirit you know good gods and
bad gods and one of the things is that
even the worst of them in some way
were would protect you against others
the ancient gods were neither
particularly they weren't necessarily
good or bad they didn't necess you know
they liked certain people they didn't
like other ones and so you're always
trying to figure out a way in which to
Curry their favor
on the other hand if you look at the
general evolution of Satan you have a
a deity which in some ways is
rooted in in these these sort of ancient
ambiguous Gods ones that could be
hostile but you could probably bring
over to your side in some way you know
by you know again sacrificing a goat or
your children or whatever might be
necessary
but then you also have one which in more
modern times Satanism becomes this kind
of well
it becomes a flip side of Christianity
what do I mean by that well the the key
ritual in sort of modern Satanism is
something called the black mass
who else has a mass well the Roman
Catholic Mass the Eastern Orthodox Mass
but that's something which is which is
which is specific to Christianity and in
particularly in Western Europe to the
Roman Catholic church and the black mass
is really this just this sort of
inversion or parody of it
and what that means in a sense is that
really what was termed Satanism had no
independent existence of its own it was
only the inverse of something else and
it it then became in some ways a kind of
anti-church a kind of anti-christianity
something that if you wanted to you know
basically
defy everything that was considered to
be the proper rules of behavior that's
what it was that you would go to you
would do the opposite of what you've had
before sure okay Rick so we got a few
questions from our social media
followers about the occult and your
series let's start with this one from
Emily r on Facebook who asks what is the
most real world danger that the occult
poses
well again the occult is
a philosophy and a tool book whether a
toolbox of techniques to access this
larger world I was discussing and
larger world again is
full of all kinds of things
so if you venture out into the
wilderness
without proper equipment and preparation
you know you go barefoot without a coat
without any kind of fire making it
you're going to run into trouble
so for instance
um you know if an occultist is going to
use a ritual to summon something from
this world you know the
theme sort of spirit well you're at a
Great Lengths
in order to prepare magic circles
talismans the whole ritual has to be
carried out in a way this is preparing
yourself for a venture into this world
in the same way that you would prepare
yourself to go into the wilderness and
when you're done you want to send away
whatever you're doing this is where you
get things like banishing rituals as the
saying goes never call up what you
cannot put down
other words don't get involved with
something that you can't deal with so
the occult isn't something again which
is inherently in and of itself evil or
dangerous any more than nature is evil
or dangerous but it can be and it has to
be approached with preparation and
caution
so you actually answered for the most
part the next question we had from Ramon
L on Twitter who asked is the occult
ever linked to good causes or is it by
definition nefarious
it comes down to your intent what do you
intend to do
now again if you're going out into the
woods if you're going out into nature
what is your intention
are you going there just to wander among
the flowers and appreciate the
butterflies or you're going there to
hunt for food I mean that's a big
difference to whatever it is you're
going to encounter on the whole are you
are you know just going on a hike or
you're going to go Prospect for gold
what do you what do you wish your
intention is what guides every other
action your intention
we'll have a great deal with whatever it
is that you attract to you
so here's one that
um is very specific to a very particular
part of the occult Doug M on Instagram
asks at what point did a mainstream toy
manufacturer decide to align itself with
occult rituals I.E the Hasbro Ouija
board the Ouija board
the modern board goes back to not
tensborough or to Parker Brothers but to
a fellow by the name of Charles Canard
back in the in I think in 1891 it's when
the modern Ouija board comes along
and he teamed up with a fellow by the
name of William fold who was you know I
kind of game and and Novelty
manufacturer and they actually got a
patent for this
and the interesting way to do it if
you're going to get a patent for it you
have to in some way demonstrate that
whatever it is you're trying to patent
actually works how are you going to
demonstrate that that actually works
well in this case they brought in a
medium a Woman by the name of Ellen
Peters who use the board and attested to
the patent officials there that yes
indeed she was contacting spirits
and you know they bought it and thus it
was born
um you then passed into something called
the William fold company which
manufactured the boards I think they had
the exclusive rights up until 1966. uh
and then in 1966 Parker Brothers got it
and then it went further on
why did Parker Brothers or Hasbro when
he would become involved because there
was money in it great answers Rick uh we
need to take a quick break but can you
stick around
sure can all right I'd like to take a
quick moment to remind you that guests
on this show are experts from our family
here at one real in addition a series
about secret societies you'll also find
topics like Science History mental
health and even foreign language
instruction and personal development
there's something for everyone on one
dream
and now with the recent edition of
hundreds of documentaries and how-to
series there's never been a better time
to join if you want to binge watch
something watch something that's smart
by experts on biodiversity my own
history physics art
streaming is a lot smarter with one
dream one dream because I wonder
knowledge is now streaming at wandrium
so Rick your Illuminati video from your
previous series called secret societies
which is also streaming on one Dream
It's Quickly becoming one of our
all-time most viewed lectures that I
have posted to our YouTube channel it's
captured the imagination of a huge
audience it's solicited quite a few I'm
going to say enlightening comments but I
want to run some of them by you here in
a segment I'd like to call them
are you are you ready
I'm ready all right so of course we got
a lot of great comments such as good
narrator's voice heart emoji and I love
you guys
as well as the fact is this video is
great deserve uncountable views those
are the good ones
um but I also got a lot of comments like
this
who are the Illuminati not who were they
so my question to you is does the
Illuminati still exist
so what I deal with in the secret
societies course the Illuminati that I'm
talking about in that episode is the
Bavarian Illuminati that is a thing
called the illuminatan Orden in German
which is historically recorded it was
real it was around not for very long in
the late 18th century sort of came and
went between about 1776 and you know
1786 and was and was formed and led by a
fellow by the name of Adam Vice Hout who
indeed had a very you know detailed and
rather practical plan for world
domination
so that's the one that you can see so
that's what I'm dealing with there but
here's an interesting thing about the
Bavarian Illuminati
or a couple of interesting things one
they're not the first group that called
themselves the Illuminati which is
simply Latin for those who are
illuminated those who've seen the light
in some ways
if you go back to the Roman era and you
look at early Christian communities you
know one sort of hiding out in the
catacombs
they often would refer to themselves as
Illuminati because they had seen the
light the
truth had been revealed to them and
therefore an early Christian was an
illuminatus and there were many other
groups that used that term in one form
or another and we're not even talking
about people who spoke languages other
than Latin who had words that also meant
those who had seen the light so the
Illuminati were everywhere so Adam Vice
Health did not invent the term
but the second point
is that the Bavarian Illuminati because
they had an essentially subversive
political agenda
were discovered and suppressed by the
Bavarian Royal government
in the 1780s
but they weren't destroyed So Adam
weishauft was never arrested or put on
trial he simply moved to another German
state where the prince was guess what a
member of the Illuminati Order and he
lived until
until the 1830s and continued to
correspond with all of his Illuminati
buddies and none of them were arrested
and killed either I mean there was never
any Mass Roundup of the organization it
just got chased out of Bavaria and it
went elsewhere
so the point is is that it was never
really destroyed
and therefore since the Bavarian
Illuminati while they cease to function
in Bavaria it continued but in a much
less visible form than it did otherwise
which means that it it is indeed
historically possible and even plausible
that the order continued to function one
of the other things that Vice Health
told his followers is let our order
never be known publicly under its actual
name
which raises a couple of questions as to
what the actual name was which you know
is that the order of the Illuminati or
was that itself a cover name
now those again are all things which are
real those are the things that Vice
Health said the reality is the order
existed the order was never destroyed
and that is I think at the root of many
of the comments or much of the
subsequent I guess we'll call it
mythology that the Illuminati are still
around that they're still ruling the
world today that in some way you know
Beyonce is a member of the Illuminati
everybody in the music industry and the
movies are influenced by them that's
where the idea comes because there's no
end to it
and
so again you're you're dealing with
something
that could exist but
in what form under what name with what
particular agenda in mind right so
that's where the legend is there uh and
how much truth there is in that well
that all depends
it is not going away
it's not going away so of course when it
comes to conspiracy theories you know
it's only a matter of time before JFK
comes into the discussion so here's a
good one
um and I apologize if it sounds like I'm
stumbling through the words I'm reading
it in which it was written JFK's famous
speech and he knew who he was dealing
with and how these evil societies grow
in their evilness and would take full
control they assassinated him
so what about it did the Illuminati have
JFK assassinated
referred to here
I think this is a speech that he gave to
the American newspaper Publishers
Association in
1961. so soon after he was elected
and it's a speech that goes into a
number of things but one of the things
that he was addressing is that you know
secrecy is he argues is essentially
Un-American and and secret societies you
know groups that attempt to secretly
influence politics and Society is is an
Un-American type of thing and we have to
be opposed to that
it's an interesting thing to be talking
to newspaper Publishers about but you
know did did Kennedy in a public address
seem to condemn
uh what he viewed as a kind of Nefarious
influence of secret societies groups
that were attempting to secretly
influence politics Society culture
whatever it might be he did
he also was assassinated a couple of
years later all right you've got those
two things those are part of the record
those are real now the connection
between them is is an assumption
I'm not saying that you know the writer
that question is right or wrong I'm just
saying that what does that mean
remember is is was his assassination in
some way a consequence of his opposition
to secret societies
you can believe that you can imagine
that you can't prove it just as you
can't prove most things but that again
is where these ideas these comments
arise from
so here's a commenter that wants to
address how the Illuminati is currently
operating
um what makes you think that this is in
the past it's absolutely huge the
influencers so to speak subliminal or
outright they do mind control 100
percent
so what do you think Rick our
influencers members of the Illuminati
that are controlling our minds
so one can create a
a holy irrational idea that in some way
the Bavarian Illuminati mutated and if
continued to mutate since the 18th
century into something else but you
can't show me exactly what that is but
you shouldn't be able if they're doing
their job right you shouldn't be able to
pin that down
it comes down to the question are there
people trying to to influence us
subliminally yeah okay that's what
advertising is all about
I mean there there's a constant efforts
you know there are people on YouTube on
the internet who proudly call themselves
influencers you know that's a title that
people go after because of the idea that
they can influence people you know
usually to buy something
but if you can influence someone to buy
something you can influence them in
other directions the way of shaping
public opinion so that undoubtedly is
there there's a there's a vast industry
of people out there who are constantly
trying to manipulate and influence all
of this I'd like to if I could step in
sorry I didn't mean to step over your
answer but I just wanted to make the
point that as a quasi host on a YouTube
show connected with a s uh I say
subscription service that I am
officially announcing right now that I
am not now or never have been part of
the Illuminati so that's out there right
you know and and neither have I but you
know I'm I'm open to offers so here's
one a commenter proposes this what if
scenario uh
what if they caused kovid that's the
entire comment what if they caused kovid
so what are your thoughts would the
Illuminati benefit from causing a global
pandemic Rick
uh well if they own a lot of stock and
pharmaceutical companies there you go
there you go okay maybe that's it maybe
maybe they've become pharmaceutical
companies so I'd like to end here with
uh one final comment that appears to be
from the Illuminati themselves according
to their account name
the Illuminati would like us to know
that we're not only watching you but
we're also watching this video
so I'd like to say awesome and I hope
that the Illuminati checks out Rick's
new course the secrets to the occult
yeah and uh you'll get mentioned in
there too so Rick thank you so much for
joining us today and uh where can people
find out more about you and your work
or you can go to my page which is still
at the University of Idaho
u-i-d-a-h-o look under history and there
about me and my work and then also they
can check out my my uh one dream
Professor profile as well thank you so
much and I will talk to you soon all
right thank you bye-bye
and that'll do it for another episode of
one dream now to learn who our upcoming
guests are and to ask them questions
make sure to keep an eye on our social
media feeds you can find links to all of
them in the description below we'll be
back soon with another great show be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss it